un mitin de victoria en el danubio
mientras el partido gobernante fidesz de
hungría logra su cuarta victoria
consecutiva el primer ministro viktor
orbán se libra de la amenaza más real
contra su gobierno en 12 años
vemos bien nos vemos cada vez mejor
probablemente no nos hayamos visto
también como esta noche
queridos amigos hemos logrado una gran
victoria
su rival y termina y lideró una colisión
de seis partidos de oposición buscando
romper el dominio de orbán sobre la
política nacional aunque el propio
márquez se mostró poco optimista al
emitir su voto no hay democracia en
hungría todas las reglas se han
establecido para que viktor orbán
mantenga su poder para siempre y siga
robando dinero público para siempre
hungría se inclina cada vez más hacia el
autoritarismo bajo el autodenominado
sistema de democracia y liberal de orbán
mientras defiende medidas anti el gp y
anti migrantes el primer ministro ganó
un control estricto sobre las
instituciones democráticas como los
medios de comunicación y el poder
judicial
además manipuló fuertemente el mapa
electoral a favor de feed ex aliado
durante mucho tiempo de vladimir putin
orbán utilizó la invasión rusa a ucrania
para presentar las elecciones como una
opción entre la paz o el caos hungría
acogió a refugiados ucranianos pero se
negó a enviar ayuda a kiev y se resistió
a las sanciones contra moscú durante
semanas las estaciones de radio y las
vallas publicitarias del país han estado
saturadas con mensajes a favor de fedex
que sin fundamento contra la oposición
mientras que márquez sólo tuvo un
espacio de cinco minutos en la
televisión pública